bom dia a todos
antes mas criar agradecer à organização
ram e em especial à pessoa de ser palco
não ter convidado por isso eventos extra
o espírito mas eu fui citado por
organizar este tipo de eventos que muito
prestígio à nossa faculdade
cria ainda felicitar todos os corredores
é especial do zé rui o nosso mágico e eu
digo nossa imagem porque eu também é meu
aluno e tude por acaso em san antonio
como vocês já perceberam fazer uma
proposta seguirá uma magia é sempre uma
dificuldade china em cativar a vossa
atenção portátil está mantida é
inseridos
coke é disseminar as vamos tentados e
começamos tudo diz caro que é um pouco
este espírito que o cuca é se eu tivesse
deflagrado já estava entregar mas o que
compromisso com a inovação em materiais
e dispositivos da opto eletrônica tem a
ver com conhecimento do fato o mercado
entre garis mexe a parte é aquela o
título e materiais e dispositivos
optoeletrônicos e que está ali para
focalizar da minha área de toda essa
minha eo meu é a minha forma salta mayer
área que eu faço este gás ao compromisso
e no flexal são duas palavras que me
deixem como pessoa ea maneira de os
estados na vida compromisso que porque
em tudo o que eu faço eu assumo um
compromisso para que o f
tudo aquilo que se propõe fazer é
theophin até esgotar todas as
possibilidades da minha parte e não faz
sal e no pré sal em alguma tenta em mim
e eu muitas vezes começa a olhar para as
coisas e começa a imaginar como é que eu
poderia ser modificado a ser mais
eficiente
como é que ia ser modificados para ter
outra funcionária
outra funcionalidade mais amigável por
exemplo o ambiente é sempre importante
ao que queria triste que me importante
daí o título que o percurso mas como é
quem não faz ao está funcionado com
conhecimentos e novas ao conhecimento
imagina sal é um treino meu que pra mim
é hindu sines sociável
nós porém no fax exames de conhecimentos
mas precisamos também de meus lizzie
imaginação não conseguimos envolver
qualquer coisa senão corremos a nossa
imaginação mexe também precisamos do
conhecimento
a inside cia que imaginei sal era mais
importante do que o conhecimento nem
acontece eu tava servir uma imaginação
mais abstrata é que ela imagina sal que
está dissociado do conhecimento se é que
existe é imaginação por exemplo não sou
eu a pensar como é que nós adoraríamos
neste novo é isso ou imaginação que leva
a pensar como é que nós conseguimos o ar
com os passas
portanto é uma imaginação que está há
menos 60 e no conhecimento mas mais no
pensamento abstrato mas imagine sal que
nós precisamos para e não fato é uma
imagina sal mais assente no conhecimento
daquilo que nós conhecemos nossa dia a
dia e como é que nossa e queriam ser
conhecimento o conhecimento é alto nós
adquirimos várias formas pela nossa
formação acadêmica pela nossa vivência e
sobretudo como também pela nossa
obsessão das coisas e que nós somos
todos diferentes todos nós
concessionamos o maior entre as
circunstâncias de maneira diferente e o
conhecimento para mim é algo que como
tinho
vamos adquirindo conhecimentos esse
conhecimento qualquer coisa que nós
fizemos poderão eram os novos aprendemos
quando estamos nós fica armazenado no
nosso cérebro e como nós precisamos
formular fiscal e por isso também pelo
fato nós temos conhecimento como um
ativo que me faz em causa muita tristeza
o modo como a nossa sociedade trata as
pessoas mais idosas e este é provar e
desaproveitou conhecimento que ela está
isso é relativamente ao conhecimento
tanto conhecimento está em tudo aquilo
que nos rodeia em toda a nossa vivência
digamos assim imaginação e mexer na sal
é mais difícil bem cedo e eu no meu caso
como diz earl estava atento
mas penso que também será altimétrico
que dom terá a sua capacidade de
imaginar e ter ideias iria ser
publicados
a idéia é algo muito interessante e
muito
fernanda t eu já dei por mim em várias
instituições e falar com players lewis
estava um pouco é tem um desenvolvimento
um pouco limitado óó parado no tempo não
conseguiu incluídos entre os vícios
basta apenas e por que não faz assim
para um trabalho desbloquear que
conseguirem fluídos e como é que eu
aplico o meio da ikea tem porque quer
pôr em prática agora estamos a ir um
pouco para mais provável que a qualquer
tempo de lançar o tema e mente que o que
está em fato e eu tenho uma ideia a
ideia só queria que vocês não ficassem
com é um santo que todas as idéias
funciona há muitas idéias que não
funcionam todos e há outras ideias
tristes conseguem pôr isso em prática
então voltando como é que o texto as
linhas cidades primário vou pro
laboratórios primeiro
minha turma do edifício se funciona
muito bem tento reproduzir funciona
ainda niote ok e agora proponho é que eu
aquela temática como tema disse pertence
ao brasil onde de mestrado normalmente e
foi isso mesmo tem tido a sorte de vir
alunos que têm a coragem de aceitar esse
desafio e portanto parte da minha
instituição tem sido fácil da minha
universal tem sido feito com a ajuda de
alunos de mestrado e off menta na ítalo
de doutoramento sempre tanto tem
evoluído muito nesse sentido com a ajuda
de seu monte tem alguns envolvimentos em
vôo foi o desenvolvimento em 2009 o bb
triste papel e também de biometria com
dois alunos de mestrado seis meses e
nessa altura com qualquer
desenvolvimento
os alunos tenham muito pouco trabalho de
base e então esse é uma grande
dificuldade mas a reconstituição que
depois nós fizemos o nosso trabalho ser
conhecido e neste cascos em uma pesquisa
por baterias isso loss
nós vemos que há desde 2009 um
crescimento exponencial das instituições
em trabalhos relacionados importante com
todos esses envolvimentos de poesia em
2014 propus uma idéia também e não foi
dolorosa eo pino pisar descalço
esse idéia comer balanceada que mora no
jogador era baseada no trabalho que eu
tenho dos envolvidos serviu também para
que o painel confiasse eu era a pessoa
correta para desenvolver essa ideia e sd
mostrar que essa idéia era
dura nível europeu e até a nível
habitacional importantes
é isso aí um pouco o desenvolvimento a
idéia é basicamente integrates
dispositivos fotovoltaicos e
dispositivos externos elétricos conjugar
os como a bateria e fazer um dispositivo
integrado que entre os tecnológicos será
muito mais intuitivo no futuro novamente
queria ter sal já que nem todas as
idéias funciona
muitas vezes nós temos uma ideia e
sabemos que intuitivamente esse daí vai
funcionar mas vou experimentando venci
duas vezes e não funciona há muitas
situações também que nós conversarmos
com o colega e responsa cedae é sempre
mais a resposta da justiça não funciona
então sucesso à sua sorte
isso acontece muito importante a nossa
postura será nunca mas nunca de tite é
ter que todas as possibilidades tyson
disputadas importante que o que eu
aconselho e se você está em uma idéia
que querem desenvolver qualquer coisa se
eu vou à sua intuição e quem falou do
momento está baseada no conhecimento e
voz entre sanchez vai funcionar diz
seguir em frente e vão até o fim e
continue podem formar com colegas podem
falar com a mix mas no final se o
assento e sal méxico que nós fizemos com
conhecimentos mais importante que o
conhecimento que nós fizemos com ela e
para mim não faz sentido e nós temos
muito conhecimento se nós o cruzeiro só
dispor dos outros se eu não servir para
criar uma comunidade melhor como é linda
machuca sujeitada e é que tá grande
é grande tal pra mim é mais importante o
que fazemos com o conhecimento do
próprio - a oi que o que conhecemos nem
china também o desconhecido e
recentemente fiquei bastante
entusiasmada por verdes que há colegas
que estudam o efeito do meio ambientes
na água
estou aqui é um estudo que mostre que os
cristais formados de água ao som da
música quatro sessões adquirem formas em
frente com a sua queda uma dos trás
estas são imagens draw outono inverno e
portanto o facto a que todo o facebook
you
portanto a todos
o festin mil nós quanto mais aprendemos
quanto mais conhecemos melhor e melhor
também e nós temos quase nada
conhecemos muito pouco e portanto como
eu disse é esse tópico em que é
interação do do meio ambiente com a
saúde física e mental do homem ea
própria interação do homem com a
natureza é algo que de facto é explorado
não existe em todas as linhas
um ponto esse ponto de sal é algo que
nos acompanha durante a vida toda
desconhecemos é ter como hips a todas as
horas todos os minutos nossa vida nós
temos um ponto em português
a diferença só eu como é que nós lidamos
com é centro de sal
como é que nós cuidamos com o que não é
previsível como é que nós lidamos com o
kit com o índice se nós olharmos por
isso de uma forma natural e se das
dificuldades fizermos oportunidades nós
conseguimos ser pessoas melhores e que
profissionais melhores senão eu imaginei
que nós conhecíamos o caminho por onde
vamos que nós sabíamos o que iríamos
encontrar aqui e eu criamos vers
não aprendemos nada e essa seria uma
vida é boa essa que nós conhecemos
vender e ficou essa mensagem sigam as
forças entre os sóis sigam voz canning
não tenham medo de errados porque no
erro que nós vamos buscar disse
muitas vezes o homem o melhor
conhecimento melhor que eu disse não eu
tannus uipss é que o que nós aprendemos
errado e shaq hoje foi dito que o
conhecimento não pode ser nunca é
restrito o conhecimento tem que ser ao
largar tudo e tudo que nós fazemos
vemos conjugal e interno legal para
conseguir desenvolver qualquer coisa 9 e
fique com essas palavras
obrigada a tomar